welcome back well we're now on number
four and just so you know how considered
i am of your time i drew this very fancy
graphic before the video just so so not
to waste your your valuable time
so let's read the question and this is
the this is the graph that they
this and this this axis right here is
number of children number
of children
and these are years okay
so the question says
the graph above shows how the jackson
family continued to grow between 1991
and 1998
by indicating the total number of
children in the family at the end of
each year
the jacksons have one set of twins who
were born to miss jackson
one year because they couldn't have been
born to mr jackson who were born to miss
jackson one year in july during what
year were the twins born
well let's see this graph they see the
years each year they say how many
children are in the family so we can
figure out
how many children are born in each year
just by by figuring out how much does
the does the graph move up for example
there were
let me say children born children
born and you could do this in your head
during the during the exam because you
have to do it really really fast but
i'll explain it a little bit more
basically so that you make sure you get
it
so in 1991 were any children born well
no because they had no children right
in 92 they went from having zero
children 91 to having one child so one
child was born in 92
and then how many children were born 93
well they had one child in 92 and they
had one child in 93 so no children were
born
in 93
right i think you see what i'm doing i'm
getting the difference between one year
and the next because that's how many
children are born in that year
from 93 to 94 we went from one to two
children so one child was born that year
so there was one child born
same thing in 95 our the number of
children increased by one so there's one
child born
96 the number of children stayed the
same
right no new children were born we had
three at the end of 95 and we had three
at the end of 96. so no new children
were born so that's zero
and then in 97 we go from having three
children at the end of 96 to having five
so two children must have been born that
year
and then in 98
we had the same number of children and
of course they should have said in the
question but we should have you know we
can assume that no children died during
the course of this problem
i don't want to be morbid but anyway so
no children were born in 98 so zero so
the question is what year were the twins
born well twins that's two children if
my biology is correct
so the year is 1997
which is choice number d
i i feel very bad having to erase this
beautiful drawing but the things i do in
the name of education
clear
invert
all right
number five no drawing for sal and
number five the average arithmetic mean
of x and y is five so
average or let me write mean because it
has fewer letters
mean
they should have another math term
called nice i think but the mean of x
and y is equal to five
right and that what does that mean that
means that the average so we also know
that x plus y over two is equal to five
that just took the average of them
and the average of x y and z is eight
what is the value of
z fascinating so we also know that the
mean
of x
y
and z
is equal to 8
and then they want to know what is z
well the mean of x y and z is equal to
eight that's just if we took the average
album that's x
plus y
plus z
over three
is equal
to
eight right that's just this is the
exact same way of saying this you can
review the the average um uh play i
think it's in my pre-algebra playlist
and and if you don't remember how to
take averages but how do we solve for z
here because you know we have three
variables and only two equations it
seems very complicated but i'll show you
a trick and this is actually a very
common sat trig
so you take this first equation right
and we can't solve for x and we can't
solve for y but we can solve for x plus
y
so
we just multiply both sides of that
equation by two and we get x
plus y is equal to ten
right x plus y is equal to ten
x plus y is equal to ten and then we can
substitute
the whole x plus y here
right
this is something you seldom see in your
algebra classes because you're always
solving for one variable for other now
we kind of you can almost use x plus y
as a variable right like the whole thing
is a variable it's kind of strange but
that's that's how you do this problem
and i mean you know algebra there's
nothing fancy here i'm saying x plus y
is equal to 10 literally in english and
so we could say well this x plus y is
equal to 10. so we could rewrite this
top equation as 10
plus z
over 3 is equal to 8
right and then if we multiply both sides
by 3 you get 10 plus z is equal to 24
and then you subtract 10 from both sides
and you get z is equal to 14 and we are
done
that wasn't too bad was it good the
choice exists choice b for number five
all right number six some drawing for
sal
invert color oh no
in invert colors there you go
in the figure okay this is i like these
these are fun
okay let me draw in magenta
so
that's the big figure
in the figure above a small i don't know
how to change my background color i
don't
anyway in the figure above a small
square is inside a larger square what is
the area in terms of x of the shaded
reason okay well let me
let me
well let me just work with what i have
so they have a smaller one here they
have a smaller
and then
let me
use this thing create a shaded region
let me create a shaded region look at
that so look at the amazing tool i'm
using it's called paint
okay
so what was i doing oh this is x
oh i'm using the same color let me do a
vivid color this is this one side of
this is x one side of this is x
and then the sides of the big square are
five
and five
right
and they just wanna know what is the
area in terms of x of the shaded region
well the shaded region that's this brown
area
the area of that is going to be the area
of this entire square
minus the area of the smaller square
right because we took this out of the
shaded region
so the the area of the big square well
the area of a square is just or a
rectangle is just the height times the
width so that's five times five so it's
minus the area of the smaller square and
that's just going to be x times x
which is x squared
that equals the area and that is choice
e
all that drawing for such an easy
problem
i hope you don't find that you know i'm
being cocky when i call it an easy
problem if you found it difficult it
wasn't that easy i understand anyway
number seven
let me
erase my drawing
if r s t v equals one let me write that
down
r s
t v equals one
and s t u v equals zero
s t
u v to u
v stuff
equals
zero which of the following must be true
let me write these down so they're
saying
choice a i'm gonna write all the choices
ch a r is greater than oh no no no no
i'm already doing it wrong r is less
than
one
choice b
is s is less than one
choice c
[Music]
is t
is greater than one half
choice d
u is equal
to zero
and choice
e
v
is equal to zero so which of the
following must be true
well the first thing we know we know r s
t v is equal to one so we know that none
of r s t or v
can be zero because if any of them were
zero then
when you multiply them out they couldn't
equal zero right so r s t v
all must be some non-zero number right
so if we go back here we know that s is
not if we and we go into this equation
we know that one of them must be zero
right because at least one because when
you multiply them you get zero right
because zero times any number is zero
so we know that s is not zero right so
we know that s is not zero because it's
up here
because we said all of these numbers
cannot be zero we know t cannot be zero
because it's up here because if it was
zero this would have been zero and we
know v cannot be zero because it's up
here right and all we're left with is
that u is equal to zero
i'll see you in the next video